When starting your business,
it's important to find a balance between
the time and
resources you have available.
Have a look at this scale.
On one end is the resources you have and
on the other is the time it
takes to complete your goals.
You'll need to find the right balance
on the scale to manage your time and
resources effectively.
So, what happens over here?
If you're not careful
how you use your time,
you can end up trying to
do everything yourself.
This could save you resources but
it forces you to focus on daily tasks
rather than the growth and
stability of your company.
In this situation,
you probably need to go out and
find people with the right skills
to help you build your business.
Now, what happens if you don't
manage your resources effectively?
There are many ways you can run low
on resources, but here's one example.
Maybe you've done a great
job building your team and
have plenty of time to work
on growing your company.
While building a great team is
necessary, overextending your resources
can become unsustainable and
cause other problems for your business.
In this situation you may need to cut
back on the resources you're spending
by managing a few jobs yourself, or
finding cheaper ways to get it done.
Your goal is to stay
somewhere in the middle.
If you can find a way to manage both
your time and resources effectively,
you build a much better foundation for
your business to grow on.
Coming up,
you'll learn to manage this balance.
As we go through each of the options you
have for your business, keep in mind how
you plan to balance your resources
with the time you have available.